these are dipping ducks or drinking
birds or whatever you like to call them
we made a film about them about six
years ago you can still watch that but
today i'd like to look at them in a bit
more detail and in particular we'd like
to use a thermal imaging camera
but first let's have a look at how
they're made as you can see when the
felt heads removed it's essentially just
two glass bulbs connected by a tube
but it's important to note the tube
extends down here and that the liquid
inside is something like dichloromethane
a liquid that evaporates easily it's
normally clear but colored here so we
can see it better
now because the liquid so volatile it
means we have quite a bit of vapor in
this area
and importantly that vapor's sealed here
in the upper chamber because as you can
see the tube down here is below the
liquid level
now with the felt head on and that's
also important we wet the bird's beak
and water spreads through the felt
quickly encompassing the whole head
[Music]
this water then starts evaporating
cooling the head it's a bit like the
birds sweating to keep cool
and that's when things get interesting
vapor in the upper chamber starts to
condense as it cools
and that means the pressure's dropping
something called the ideal gas law would
show with the temperature and amount of
gas falling the pressure falls too
actually because of the gas liquid phase
transition this is more accurately
described by something called the
clausius clapeyron relation but that's
not quite so easy to pronounce you can
look into that more later anyway the
important thing is the higher pressure
down here where it's not cool starts
forcing liquid up the tube
we can see it
and eventually due to the toys design
the bird becomes top heavy and tips over
and now because of the clever placement
of the tube it's now above the liquid
level
the seal between the head and the tail
is momentarily broken
warm gas from below can now force its
way up the tube and the liquid drains
back down the bottom importantly the
pressure's equalized
and because the liquids drained back
down the toy tips back to the upright
position
now this can go for a long time but even
longer if we have a glass of water
placed here because the head stays wet
for as long as we choose now of course
this isn't any kind of perpetual motion
heat is constantly being extracted to
keep the water evaporating
[Music]
but speaking of heat let's try this
another way
instead of cooling the head
let's use a hair dryer to warm the tail
[Music]
now first the blow dryer actually moves
the toy into its own position but that's
to be expected but here now instead of
lowering the pressure up top we're
increasing the temperature and amount of
gas in the bottom bulb thereby
increasing the pressure down below
and again liquid is forced up the neck
and sure enough this works too
[Music]
here's a comparison you can see the hot
ones almost too hot
the neck's filled with liquid almost all
the time
[Music]
having done this i then decided well
maybe we should try a few other things
first using this tea light as a source
of heat under the bird
[Music]
look how quickly the liquid rises
and the bird stays sort of permanently
tipped
trying to force it to the vertical shows
the problem there's just too much heat a
sort of endless loop of liquid and hot
gases being forced up the tube by the
high pressure below
here you can see just how much the lower
section is being heated
so next i tried putting the tea light
here hoping for a gentler application of
heat to that bottom bulb
[Music]
just a little bit of liquid creeping up
but never quite enough to tip the bird
and it was thermal imaging that revealed
the problem you can see the tea light is
actually applying tremendous heat to the
top bulb
the gas pressure up top is increasing
pressing down on the liquid exactly what
you don't want
now okay here's something else and i
really didn't know what to expect this
time how will the drinking bird work if
you use really hot or freezing cold
water before watching do you have any
guesses
well after an initial dunk and letting
the water spread the cool-headed bird
pretty much works properly what you'd
expect
[Music]
but the hot-headed bird that's more
interesting
the heat in the head must be keeping the
gas pressure in the top bulb too high
preventing the liquid from being forced
up the neck of course
but watch closely
evaporative cooling starts to kick in
the temperature drops the pressure drops
the higher pressure below now does its
job forcing liquid up the neck the bird
starts dipping as it over balances
it's gradual and actually the mere act
of dipping puts more heat into the head
stalling the process you can see it
but eventually the back part of the head
becomes cool enough and it's business as
usual
in fact though the beak's been
constantly replenished with hot water as
you can see
the back part of the head stays cool
enough
and soon you can see the two birds are
dunking pretty much similar rates
if you'd like to go back and watch our
original video with professor phil
moriarty about these dipping birds i'll
include a link on the screen and in the
description
and thanks to professor moriarty for
helping me out with this video and
lastly also a big thanks to google's
making and science team if you'd like to
see more films with various youtubers
they've supported there are also links
on the screen and in the description
[Music]